you and Katie were in a surveillance van
for night one of Hannah's premiere how
much did you guys spill to Hanna how did
it all go we were in a van and we had
cameras and we were listening in to all
the conversations with Hanna and the
guys and the guys and the guys so yeah
we were just trying to make sure that
everyone was there for her and it seems
like from a trailer we've seen Hanna
finds out a night one that there's a guy
with a girlfriend how dramatic is this
night one it's very dramatic and it's
juicy and ah Hanna is awesome and she
rocked it and she handled it flawlessly
but here's the thing
I know Hanna's gonna take you guys's
information into consideration but like
how much do you think Hanna listens to
what you said or what anybody says
during the season because she's such a
Spitfire um I think that she knows that
like we have her best interests at heart
and she trusts us as her friends to make
sure that you know our information is
valid and we're not just saying it off
of a rumor you know we did our research
and yeah it's good well knowing her what
kind of guy do you think she could
potentially end up with after all this
definitely somebody who's religious
somebody who is a man and isn't scared
of anything you know you the Beast needs
a strong man so yeah just somebody who
can keep up with her I mean I mean we're
hoping and I think Chris Harris has been
pretty obvious about the fact that
you're gonna go to paradise so when you
were in the van were you kind of eye on
any of those guys like oh maybe if he
doesn't work out with Hanna I could be
on the beach with him I mean if I do go
to paradise like I definitely was
scoping him out and I was like Hanna
save that one for me I just interviewed
Colton and Cassie on Friday and they
talked about how Colton kind of has this
brother-sister relationship with Kailyn
now which was sort of that is insane
tell me what you think of it um I think
that you know just for their situation
like it's difficult because they are
such close friends I think that they
realize like they had to like come to
some kind of agreement to where they
could all be friends and hang out and I
know Kailyn wants Cassie to be happy and
vice-versa so I mean it's kind of weird
and it's crazy but I think that it is
true and it's genuine and
I mean she's happy for her girl and they
have to get along you've said you really
thought it was gonna be you what is you
and Colton's a relationship like now
Colton and I are homies it's so fun
whenever he sees me I think he's still
scared of me but we have a good time
whenever we get to see each other
alright so paradise happens and then
Demi's the next Bachelorette yes oh my
god that would be the dream hello if we
see you in paradise
how is Demi attacking that Beach what
would your style be on the show well
we're renaming it Demi dice if I go I'm
gonna run that Beach I've got to be the
queen you know me it's gonna be really
fun I'm just gonna have a lot of fun
what would your strategy be like dating
wise though is it gonna be good are you
gonna lock on one guy right away or kind
of survey the situation what do you
think I think I'm gonna be open-minded
and I'm not gonna like you know jump
into something right away I think I need
to like weigh out all my options like
you know it probably would be easy to
like get really involved with someone
right away but then you know it's
paradise and people can come in later so
what if you know someone else comes in
later like I just need to keep it open
and play the field night one how would
you just tease you and Katie in the van
like what kind of adjectives would you
use to describe what you guys bring to
the table Katie and I in the van on
night one we're definitely we're looking
out for Hanna where Hanna's Angels we
have a good time or maybe a little bit
mean but it's funny you know I mean a
little critical but it's because we're
protective of her so were there any guys
when you saw them and you were like Oh
Hanna will definitely be into that guy
and oh that guy's definitely I know oh
absolutely any guy with like a weak
personality I was like oh she's gonna
eat him alive did she listen to you guys
on night one yeah absolutely
yes Lauren Bushnell kind of admitted
that when she was on the show you know
maybe she thought she was in love with
Ben Higgins but she said he didn't
really have her whole heart when you're
there in the moment though like is that
how you feel because I remember you said
you really thought Colton was gonna pick
you like did you think he had your whole
heart and looking back he didn't how
would you describe it I think that
you're like in a bubble effect and I
guess all you're thinking about is this
guy and thinking about the potential of
a relationship and what you can do to
impress him and all this stuff and you
don't see anybody else out there in the
world so your main focus is on this one
guy so I think that in the moment it's
very elevated your emotions are and you
can fall for somebody a lot ease a lot
easier than you can like in the regular
world because you know you only have one
option in the bachelor world paradise is
gonna be different I know it's gonna be
a lot more fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]